Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie. This will
be my black panther wakanda forever review I
had a chance to see the movie so there's a bunch
to talk about if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get the videos I will
do a full post credit scene video Easter eggs
breakdown of the entire movie later this week
after it comes out in theaters everywhere one
of the big changes heading into this movie is that
it is the end of Marvel phase 4 and it's meant to
bookend everything that happens in Marvel phase
4 which is them introducing a whole bunch of new
Concepts and new characters and starting off this
Multiverse Saga whereas before we get an Avengers
movie at the end of each phase now we just get the
Avengers movies at the end of each Saga which is
Marvel phase six for this Multiverse Saga compared
to the first movie it's much bigger in scope and
size and obviously in the context of Chadwick
boseman's death there was just a lot of stuff
that they had to handle they also used the movie
to literally within the MCU set up a bunch of
storylines for a bunch of different things so even
though it's not an Avengers movie they wanted to
feel as big as an Avengers movie it also shares
a really interesting connection with Avenger
end game so one of The Producers Nate Moore said
that they wanted the movie to feel like Avengers
end game and not have a traditional post-credits
scene but there is a mid-credit scene during the
movie just not a traditional post-credits scene
so do stay during the credits I will talk about
what's in that scene during my full post credit
scene video later this week Kevin feige called
this one of the most important movies that they'd
ever made that's not just a statement about the
overarching plot of the MCU heading forward into
Avengers 5 and Avengers 6. he's mostly referring
to the context of Chadwick boseman's passing in
the circumstances that they found themselves in at
Marvel Studios when they were choosing to make the
movie at all like they could have just decided to
pack up and not make any more Black Panther movies
they also decided not to recast the character of
t'challa and how they addressed that through the
plot and the themes of the movie all just very
very important heavy things that they had to deal
with so the movie itself is as much a tribute to
the life of t'challa within the MCU like they pay
tribute to him very literally during the plot of
the movie but is also meant to be a tribute to
Chadwick Boseman in real life one of the first
things they did when they were meeting to actually
start production for black panther wakanda forever
and talk about what they were going to do for
the movie was deciding to leave number one on the
call sheets empty in honor of Chadwick Boseman so
Leticia writes shuri character for example she'd
be essentially the main character normally she'd
be listed as number one in the call sheets instead
they listed her as number two and they just left
number one blank as if Chadwick Boseman were there
with them at every step making the movie his
family was also involved in the making of black
panther wakanda forever as well if you actually
read wakandan congratulations because it's amazing
it is an actual language that they created for
the first movie the same way that they created
the Dothraki the High Valyrian languages for Game
of Thrones and I don't consider it a spoiler to
say that inside the throne room in this scenes in
the trailer here you see the special inscriptions
on the pillars around the throne in the wakandan
language decoded these read rest in Power King
t'challa our hero it has been an honor wakanda
forever and that's like their tribute to Chadwick
Boseman in real life but but also t'challa inside
the MCU the movie in general is also just about
dealing with Chadwick Boseman and t'challa's death
how do shuri raimonda all the other characters
deal going forward how does wakanda move forward
after this and how do they move forward after the
snap Ryan coogler the director said that before
Chadwick Boseman passed away the plot was going
to be very different because Chadwick bothman was
going to be the main character and the movie was
mostly going to deal with how he decides to move
forward after the tragedy of the snap but in real
life Chadwick Boseman very literally passed away
right after Ryan coogler finished the first script
so he wasn't able to actually read that and when
he did obviously they had to completely rewrite
the movie around that personally I think they did
a great job because there's almost no way to win
in a situation like that it is a very crowd-worthy
movie like there's a lot of dramatic moments you
go through the entire roller coaster like you do
during a lot of these really really big movies and
there was a lot of crying during Spider-Man no way
home but for slightly different reasons more for
Nostalgia reasons like crying for Tobey Maguire
and Andrew Garfield coming back this time with
wakando forever you'll be crying for different
reasons crying for Chadwick Boseman passing away
and then addressing that during the movie as you
can see in a lot of the clips very literally the
characters talk to each other about what they do
now that t'challa is dead how do they go forward
there's a lot of grief going around inside wakanda
and then they have to deal with what's happening
with Namor in this fight between these two
cultures which is the other big part of the
plot is how do they address this other brand new
place inside the MCU that's been hidden this whole
time is sort of like another version of wakanda
but underwater and I know a lot of people will be
asking about their decision to not recast t'challa
after Chadwick boseman's passing the way that
Kevin feige talked about it the way the producer
Nate Moore talked about it even the director Ryan
coogler said that they just felt like it was way
too soon after Chadwick boseman's passing to even
think about doing something like that and because
Chadwick Boseman meant so much to so many people
it would have felt wrong to just turn around and
recast him right after that Frank hugler even said
for a little while they almost decided to not make
a movie at all like no more Black Panther movies
talking about some of the performances Letitia
Wright's shuri even though it's an ensemble film
she is arguably probably the main character she's
a great actress I loved her in the first movie
obviously in this movie she has to step up in a
really big way but also had to do that in real
life to fill the vacuum that's left by chadwick
boseman's t'challa in one of her big struggles in
the movie is proving herself amidst that because
she is quite literally very tiny but she's meant
to be one of the smartest people in the MCU so
the whole idea is that how does shuri figure out
how to be another great black panther given what
t'challa did with the mantle how does she become
a symbol for wakanda wakanda's protector in what
is the role of the Black Panther going forward
versus what it used to be within the MCU like
the movie addresses the whole idea of the Black
Panther role itself within the MCU within the
history of their people Danai Gurira was awesome
as akoye they've been talking about doing a solo
spin-off series just for her on Disney Plus for a
while now it's not gonna happen for a little while
but that just gives you an idea for how important
they think that she is as a character inside the
MCU she's a very similar role that she had in the
first movie she's been a general been the head of
the door milage for a long time but when they're
talking about the role of the Black Panther within
wakanda like how do they move forward she's meant
to be the voice of tradition like we've always
done things in wakanda this way we have these
certain traditions our culture has always done
things a certain way so she's that voice on that
side of the aisle then on the other side of that
coin you have people like shuri other characters
that they introduce in the movie like Michaela
Cole's Anika character who want to try new ideas
incorporate new things into their Traditions New
Concepts that might make things better but are
very different from what wakandans did before in
fact I know there are a lot of people that were
wondering who the New Black Panther was going to
be in the movie and that is very literally one of
the plot points of the movie is in them deciding
who the next Black Panther is going to be who has
the right to become the next Black Panther in
what is their role within their culture going
forward and a lot of the different voices are
battling it out over what their Traditions have
been and what their Traditions should be or could
be in the future like no no we don't always have
to do things the way we've always done them we
can change things incorporate new ideas and make
things better which is basically what Chadwick
boseman's t'challa was trying to do at the end
of the first Black Panther movie open wakandan's
borders which is how you get all those jokes
about Starbucks in Olympics inside wakanda Lupita
nyong'o was great as Nakia she was obviously very
important to the plot of the first movie but she's
a much bigger character during this one and going
forward as well they also addressed a little bit
about what they were up to on their own the two
of them before t'challa's passing they had an
implied relationship during the first movie but
they just expand on that during this film a lot of
questions obviously about Riri Williams ironheart
and the MCU Dominique Thorne the actress was great
as the character they kind of use her as a bit of
comedic relief during the movie a little bit of
the Iron Man energy too just because of where
her character comes from in the comics there are a
lot of Iron Man Easter eggs with her character but
one of the big things and one of the reasons
why they included her in this movie and used
it to introduce her rather than introducing
her during armor wars or a more Iron Man's
specific series or even just waiting to the
ironheart series in general is because they
want her character to feel completely different
from Iron Man's so there are a couple jumping off
points where it feels very similar to Iron Man
but then it completely diverges once she makes
it to wakanda her character is one of like the
really big things big plot points that they set
up in the MCU going forward the ironheart series
that they're going to release next year will be a
direct sequel to Black Panther wakanda forever
Angela Bassett was fantastic as Ramada she is
on a tear in this movie She's also the voice
of tradition in the movie as well kind of like
a koye Michaela Coel was fantastic as the Aneka
character one of the new ones they introduced from
the comics through the midnight angels characters
that's another big thing too if you're a big fan
of the Black Panther Comics Nate Moore said that
they had a lot a lot of plans to introduce other
characters for instance from tahanahasi codes
run on the Black Panther character so if you're
looking to read ahead on the other stuff that
they might introduce through the future movies and
other Marvel movies just in general from wakanda
his run would actually be a good place to look
and then obviously we have to talk about tenoch
huerta is Namor huge character in the MCU just
contextually because he's a mutant and obviously
we're getting up to the place where we're seeing
more X-Men more mutant characters in the MCU like
Ms Marvel was the last big place we're starting
to hear about all these mutants that have been
here this whole time that we're just learning
about now the actor was fantastic in his portrayal
and his role in the movie he is another voice of
tradition like he's meant to be about 500 years
old when the movie picks up so he's extremely
long-lived and his role inside his culture is
a little bit like Odin's inside the asgardians
culture extremely long-lived ruling over his
people extremely powerful but because they're
so long lived they have all these Traditions
from long long ago that they hold on to even
though obviously their technology their weapons
are all very Advanced they play him a little bit
more like an anti-hero in the movie because they
do have big plans for Namor and the other members
of his culture going forward like they're going
to be very important to the foundation of the MCU
in the same way that wakanda in Black Panther
character are very important to the MCU going
forward they did make a big change with their
backstory so instead of calling it Atlantis in
the MCU they're calling it talocan and instead of
being based on Roman culture like the name or name
is very literally an anagram of Roman in the MCU
their people are based more on the Mayan and the
Aztec cultures like his people refer to him as
the snake God in the movie because of his mutant
Powers they said one of the reasons for doing
that was trying to give them a very relatable
but very unique culture in the MCU also at the
same time making it feel very different from the
Aquaman character in the version of DC's Atlantis
one of the other big things that they try to use
the movie to set up is just wakandan in Black
Panther's role going forward in the MCU they
wanted wakanda to feel like a much more central
place to the overall world in the MCU even though
we're not totally sure when Black Panther 3 is
going to come out what that means is that wakanda
is a plot point will be very big going forward
in Marvel phase five I've already addressed this
in some of my other videos but one of the big
ideas that the movie addresses in a plot point
that they sort of pick up on from the end of the
first Black Panther movie is where wakanda exists
geopolitically within the MCU because heading into
the first Black Panther movie most of the world
just thought that wakanda was this Backwater place
but then at the end of that first movie t'challa
reveals them to the rest of the world the United
Nations and they find out that they have all this
vibranium all this technology and during this
movie they addressed that like the whole idea
that the rest of the world now wants what they
have for better and For Worse like there are a
lot of good characters out there like you have the
other Avengers who are all allies to them you also
have all the villains out there all the bad guys
too like your doctor dooms Thunderbolt Rosses your
Vals, who want everything that they have and a
lot of the consequences of that will continue
forward into Marvel phase five it's also what's at
the Crux of namor's beef with wakanda during the
movie he's mad because t'challa revealed what
they had to the world and that sort of turned
them on to looking for vibranium around the world
which is what helps them uncover talocan and his
people one of the other things that makes Namor
so powerful is that yes he has all those mutant
abilities he can fly he's super strong he's crazy
strong he's almost as strong as the Hulk when he's
near body water his people also have underwater
vibranium like wakanda isn't the only place on
Earth to find vibranium so while the world is now
looking for every scrap of vibration they can find
everyone's now threatening his city trying to take
it from them but heading forward into Avengers 5
Kang Dynasty Avengers 6 secret words all the other
big Avengers crossovers like Captain America 4 New
World Order the Thunderbolts movie cannot wait
to see how they incorporate the New Black Panther
character in wakanda just in general with all
those other plots I'm pretty sure wakanda would
also be pretty interested in that giant Celestial
that's stuck in the Indian Ocean too even though
it's not part of their territory technically Suri
would want a piece of that just as much as anybody
else in the world talking about the music though
the music was fantastic the original score as well
as though the tracks They put on it Rihanna made
a song for it called Lift Me Up it was fantastic
it was her first new song in over six years and
she said specifically her reason for coming out of
retirement was to honor Chadwick boseman's passing
once you've had a chance to see the movie though
just post all your reactions in the comments below
and please don't post spoilers if you do have a
chance to see it early I will do my full post
credit scene video on Friday and then my full
breakdown Easter eggs on Saturday because there is
a lot a lot to talk about during this movie and a
lot of it is very very spoilery there are a couple
really really big twists that I think people will
get really excited about heading into black
panther 3 in Black Panther four yes I do think
that they will continue to Black Panther four like
they're making four Captain America movies they're
definitely gonna make four Black Panther movies
congratulations Xavier Ramirez you're the giveaway
winner from my last big black panther video please
email me on the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details everyone click here for
my black panther wakanda forever post credit scene
video I'll update the link as soon as I post that
later this week and click here for my new Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania trailer video with a
whole bunch of Kang the Conqueror because he
is like the next big person will be talking a
lot about because that movie is coming out in
February thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!